all right drew if you want the salt
sugar rim you got to get it in the rim
i like it
[Music]
hey i'm drew brees i was quarterback in
new orleans for 15 years and i'm isaac
toops award winning cajun chef from new
orleans today we are going to mix up
some great game day drinks for a fun
afternoon of home dating
all right juices we're both from new
orleans i thought we'd do a riff on a
mint julep and make a ginger mint
margarita so i know how to do the
original margarita but you're gonna have
to show me how to do the ginger mint so
the original margarita is one ounce
cointreau
two ounces tequila
one ounce fresh lime juice
so where do i go from here just three
more ingredients you need ginger you
need mint and you need a salt sugar rim
but let's make things interesting okay
how about this you have to hit different
targets around the property and for
every target you hit i'll give you an
ingredient i know you're retired you
watch a lot of games from the house
these days but you think you still got
it well i want the ginger mint with the
sugar and salt rim so i better hit them
all i think you still got it in you all
right let's do this let's do it
all right drew you want the ginger yeah
you got to hit the tennis balls okay
here we go
[Applause]
[Music]
nice all right we got the ginger
all right we're going to add our two
slices of fresh ginger
you got the ginger if you want the mint
you got a line drive it to the tennis
balls
right in the numbers
you want to get about five mint leaves
in there all right drew you got the
ginger you got the mint but if you want
the salt sugar rim you got to get it in
the rim
i like it
oh close
[Music]
ginger mint here we go here we go
all right we'll give it a good muddling
shake her up
gonna rim the glass all the way around
give it a dip in our salt and sugar mix
ginger garnish ginger garnish all right
fresh mint leaf well it looks good too
doesn't it congratulations cheers
ah delicious that is delicious good
shooting